and the Oscar goes to no country for old
man Scott Rudin you can enjoy producer
this is an unbelievable honor and a
complete surprise so many people have a
part of this chief among them Cormac
MacCarthy who wrote a wonderful book
that it was an honor to make into a
movie cuz the the three men sitting down
front Josh Brolin Tommy Lee Jones Javier
Bardem without them there would be no
movie these two gentlemen
I can't think of anybody I would rather
be standing here with the two of you
thank you so much for this everybody at
Vantage and Miramax who financed the
movie together the entire team at mera
Max who did a brilliant brilliant job
selling it thank you to all of them I
want to thank Mark Roybal it's a
pleasure to work with him every day I
want to thank my friend Sydney [ __ ]
who taught me that with the
responsibility with it with it with the
opportunity to make movies comes the
responsibility of making them good this
is for him this is also from my partner
John Barlow without you honey this would
be hardware thank you so much thank